Caption: we've got Ben Lowry talking about
Caption: offline first not offline mode
Caption: hey everybody uh so yeah hearing to talk
Caption: about offline first not offline mode
Caption: like courageous Set uh if you don't have
Caption: any idea what that might be related to
Caption: it's basically talking about
Caption: applications that work offline now it
Caption: can be difficult to build an app that
Caption: works offline
Caption: there are a bunch of challenges and
Caption: stuff that we'll talk about as we go on
Caption: um and obviously a lot of benefits that
Caption: come with it otherwise why would you
Caption: bother
Caption: right off the bat I want to thank
Caption: whichever DDD volunteer made this slide
Caption: it's really nice uh the rest of the talk
Caption: is more like this
Caption: good old click-a-thon there we go
Caption: so nice plan don't expect the flashy
Caption: stuff you just saw
Caption: so
Caption: I'll talk a little bit about me I'm Ben
Caption: Lowry a lead consultant at Telstra
Caption: purple I've spoken and did it a few
Caption: times before you may have seen me up
Caption: there
Caption: or if you're in Karen's talk just before
Caption: this I've featured pretty heavily on
Caption: that so um you may recognize me there
Caption: too
Caption: uh
Caption: I want to thank for the other sponsors I
Caption: know I think one particular volunteer I
Caption: don't actually know who it was but
Caption: everyone who's volunteered and all the
Caption: sponsors who have gone into making today
Caption: happen it's a big deal and the event
Caption: doesn't happen without them
Caption: cool so an offline application what is
Caption: an offline application uh well it's an
Caption: application that works offline
Caption: that much is clear uh we're going to
Caption: talk about you know why you'd want to
Caption: build one what benefits you get from
Caption: doing it and some of the challenges
Caption: that come from that
Caption: in terms of how you'd actually do that
Caption: I'm not really going to get too much
Caption: into specific libraries or Frameworks
Caption: it's more general advice mostly because
Caption: there are a bunch of people here you
Caption: might all be using different Tech and a
Caption: lot of this stuff is transferable if it
Caption: went specifically
Caption: I only work for three of you let's say
Caption: so why what you want to build an offline
Caption: app a big one is if you have an app that
Caption: needs to be used in remote areas
Caption: uh this is a map of 4G and and 5G if you
Caption: look at the little purple bits those are
Caption: 5G
Caption: what coverage basically from Telstra
Caption: uh so I assume that's bigger than all
Caption: the other ones but I don't know but
Caption: there's still a lot of areas in
Caption: Australia particularly in wa where you
Caption: don't get any internet so if you're
Caption: working or building an app that needs to
Caption: work say on a mine site or an oil rig or
Caption: a remote Community like maybe you're
Caption: building something for a water Corp or
Caption: something and they need to go out in the
Caption: field and use it then there are a whole
Caption: bunch of places where being offline but
Caption: still being able to do your job is
Caption: really important
Caption: another one might be if you have uh
Caption: Internet outages so this graph is
Caption: basically a cloudflare outage that
Caption: happened in June uh basically you can
Caption: see for about an hour that
Caption: the internet traffic they were serving
Caption: halved now given that cloudflare serve
Caption: about 20 of the internet in general that
Caption: all of a sudden dropped to about 10. so
Caption: 10 internet just didn't work
Caption: uh if you want to be resilient to that
Caption: and resilience is something we'll talk
Caption: about quite a bit today if you went to
Caption: Derek's talking here earlier
Caption: you probably uh have some useful tips
Caption: already I might give you a few more or a
Caption: few slightly different views of that
Caption: but what the resiliency gives you is
Caption: actually more than just when the whole
Caption: internet goes down you also get
Caption: resiliency for things like if you don't
Caption: have zero downtime deployments
Caption: or if you just have a bug in your code
Caption: where you start returning 500 is there a
Caption: configuration error or something like
Caption: that it means that users can keep doing
Caption: their work without worrying that it's
Caption: not going anywhere
Caption: so you've had to build the app in a way
Caption: that is resilient but by doing that you
Caption: get a lot of benefits
Caption: the other one is just kind of
Caption: situational uh lack of Internet so if
Caption: anyone got betraying here this morning
Caption: you may have gone through a tunnel and
Caption: maybe your internet dropped out or I
Caption: know for me personally most of the days
Caption: I go to work as I'm leaving my house
Caption: I'll start scrolling through Spotify or
Caption: something to find something to listen to
Caption: and then as I leave my house Wi-Fi get
Caption: the you know into the world I guess the
Caption: 4G or whatever then
Caption: my internet cuts out and always says
Caption: you're offline and it's a little bit
Caption: annoying that things don't work in that
Caption: period
Caption: other times you know uh you want go for
Caption: hiking or something you just find
Caption: yourself in a situation where you don't
Caption: have internet
Caption: and it's not really your fault it's only
Caption: going to be for a short time but you
Caption: just want to keep doing your job
Caption: another reason you might want to have an
Caption: offline app is for security or privacy
Caption: reasons
Caption: so to use an example of something that's
Caption: been in the news a little bit recently
Caption: in the US they
Caption: uh change some laws around abortions and
Caption: there were recommendations going around
Caption: to like delete period tracking apps and
Caption: that kind of thing because the data gets
Caption: stored in the cloud and you know maybe
Caption: they can go and I don't know petition
Caption: not petition like subpoena or whatever
Caption: one of those apps to get all that data
Caption: find out whatever they want to find out
Caption: I don't know nefarious things
Caption: uh if the data never leaves the device
Caption: then you don't have to worry about it so
Caption: much I mean they could still get your
Caption: device but it just more a targeted
Caption: attack at that point so
Caption: and then the final one that I've got
Caption: here is that it's actually oftentimes a
Caption: better experience for users it might be
Caption: faster because you don't have to wait
Caption: for it to load all the time uh you might
Caption: use less battery or less Network so in
Caption: like data constrained environments
Caption: particularly in you know places like
Caption: Africa or southeast Asia or wherever
Caption: where data isn't cheap that can be a
Caption: benefit you know you can do things on
Caption: Wi-Fi and then go offline when you're
Caption: not in Wi-Fi
Caption: so as an example of how much that's
Caption: quicker I have a colleague who worked on
Caption: a an app that has an offline mode
Caption: and they have a multi-step form so at
Caption: the top here we've got the offline mode
Caption: and at the bottom
Caption: offline first application sorry on
Caption: offline and then online
Caption: so the reason that it's faster is
Caption: basically because when I click next
Caption: one on goes straight to the next page
Caption: and the other one goes cool I'll save
Caption: what you've just done
Caption: and then I'll take you to the next page
Caption: so without that spinner things get a lot
Caption: faster and and the example is colleague
Caption: gave me was that the offline mode took
Caption: about 40 seconds to fill in this whole
Caption: form this multi-stage form or whatever
Caption: and the online one took you know 60 or
Caption: 80 seconds or something like that so you
Caption: do get some benefits from having an app
Caption: that works offline just because
Caption: it doesn't actually need to do as much
Caption: yeah
Caption: now every application is different and
Caption: there are going to be different kinds of
Caption: offline applications as well
Caption: some of them
Caption: you might need to go online periodically
Caption: some of them might kind of have a
Caption: fallback that works offline
Caption: and then others are going to have you
Caption: know kind of the full functionality
Caption: offline
Caption: it really does depend on what you want
Caption: to build and what your kind of users
Caption: needs are like Spotify for example
Caption: probably lets you download all your uh
Caption: or your tracks to play offline but you
Caption: can't use a search function to go and
Caption: find more stuff for example that's the
Caption: compromise they've made and that's just
Caption: what works for them
Caption: so I like to think of it as layering up
Caption: complexity uh at the base level you've
Caption: kind of got an app that's only a read
Caption: only those are really easy to make work
Caption: offline because you just download the
Caption: data and leave it there
Caption: the next kind of level is when you have
Caption: data that
Caption: only stays on the device it never
Caption: actually gets any further
Caption: and those again they're pretty easy you
Caption: never need to talk to the network
Caption: everything's fine
Caption: uh you might have some sort of caveats
Caption: to those where for example they
Caption: sync data to online
Caption: when you choose to so you can you know
Caption: export and import kind of stuff
Caption: one of the reasons you might want to
Caption: build one of these apps is because it's
Caption: really important that the data is
Caption: actually always available
Caption: and it's always up to date so if you
Caption: know you're not getting it from a server
Caption: somewhere then what you've got on the
Caption: device is actually
Caption: perfect right it's it's the source of
Caption: truth that's where everything goes
Caption: but just because you're not
Caption: online doesn't mean you can't have
Caption: similar same features that are online so
Caption: if we imagine like a first aid app where
Caption: you can download first date articles or
Caption: something
Caption: then you go out into the bush and you
Caption: get bit by a snake so you open up your
Caption: offline first aid application and you
Caption: type into the search snake bite
Caption: and then it goes oh you're offline I
Caption: can't return any results that's not a
Caption: great experience right so you do still
Caption: need some things to work
Caption: the next one is
Caption: pretty classic like graceful degradation
Caption: scenario you have an online app that
Caption: works online everything is editable
Caption: whatever and then when you go offline
Caption: you lose some functionality so you can't
Caption: edit anymore but you can still read all
Caption: the data to help you make decisions and
Caption: stuff it might be appropriate for
Caption: whatever you're building
Caption: um like an example could be a shopping
Caption: list or something where you can download
Caption: a shared shopping list
Caption: and directs here but you can't actually
Caption: make changes
Caption: maybe a bad example but it's the kind of
Caption: thing you could build
Caption: the next level would be where some data
Caption: is editable so
Caption: you might only be able to create stuff
Caption: but you can't edit stuff that already
Caption: exists
Caption: and then the last level of kind of
Caption: complexity and this is what we're going
Caption: to focus most on for this talk is those
Caption: apps where
Caption: just about everything works offline not
Caption: everything everything can work offline
Caption: like you can't do video streaming or
Caption: live chat or anything like that
Caption: but if you can do all of your job you
Caption: can go around
Caption: editing things and deleting things and
Caption: completing tasks or whatever then that's
Caption: a good step at least
Caption: so broadly speaking you've got offline
Caption: only and then mixed kind of offline and
Caption: online apps
Caption: so I've got an idea let's add an offline
Caption: mode to our app offline mode seems easy
Caption: I've I've sold you on all the benefits
Caption: right so let's go and do it I've already
Caption: got a to-do list app
Caption: how do I start well the first thing is
Caption: that you have to download your data to
Caption: use when you're offline
Caption: so what does that actually mean
Caption: uh downloading your data means
Caption: essentially you're going to keep a local
Caption: copy of that data
Caption: and then anytime
Caption: you use the app you just read from that
Caption: local data
Caption: it's pretty easy
Caption: um
Caption: the other part of that will be that when
Caption: you make changes you need to sync them
Caption: back up to the server
Caption: so
Caption: there are a few ways you can do this a
Caption: lot of smart people have gone into the
Caption: effort of actually deciding what that is
Caption: uh there's a thing called a crdt which
Caption: is a conflict flea replicated data type
Caption: and the idea is that
Caption: every kind of local copy of your
Caption: database and the one on the server is
Caption: actually kind of like a distributed
Caption: system and you just need to replicate
Caption: changes across them so all your Cloud
Caption: providers and stuff will probably handle
Caption: this for you in terms of like I've got a
Caption: SQL database or a table storage or dyno
Caption: ADB or something
Caption: but the way they actually do it is using
Caption: these crdts so there are three broad
Caption: categories one is Operation based which
Caption: is essentially like having a list of
Caption: uh operations that you've done so you
Caption: might say I've done a create task in my
Caption: to-do list and then you save that for
Caption: later and when you've come back online
Caption: you process all of them and go from
Caption: there another one is where you just
Caption: update the um
Caption: the local database you've got and then
Caption: have something that
Caption: basically just sends that up to the
Caption: server something on the server that
Caption: figures out what changed and saves it
Caption: that sounds really cool and there are
Caption: some tools that do it but I don't in
Caption: fact we have much experience with those
Caption: specifically
Caption: and then the other one is just the
Caption: saving changes so you get kind of
Caption: databases that have
Caption: rather than storing the state of the
Caption: thing you just keep a list of changes
Caption: and you and essentially you send those
Caption: up to a server when you come back online
Caption: now the one I'm going to talk most about
Caption: is the queue because I feel like that's
Caption: the easiest for people to reason about
Caption: it's probably the like the entry level
Caption: kind of offline mode it's it's just
Caption: doing what you're already doing but
Caption: saving it for later
Caption: so we'll have a little bit of a look at
Caption: some code there's not a lot of code here
Caption: hopefully it's something you can
Caption: reasonably understand even if you don't
Caption: write a lot of code
Caption: basically we have a to-do list and we're
Caption: going to say if I'm online then call the
Caption: API to get the to do
Caption: otherwise get it from my offline data
Caption: and then return that so
Caption: it seems okay right if you're online do
Caption: this if you're offline do that
Caption: the same kind of approach for an update
Caption: uh if we're online save that to the API
Caption: if we're offline then update the local
Caption: storage and cue the update essentially
Caption: so we can kind of generalize that to say
Caption: we've got an app that when you're online
Caption: goes from A to B it does X right
Caption: if you want to talk about offline though
Caption: that's saying if you're online do X if
Caption: you're offline do y
Caption: right it's not not impossible it's
Caption: actually not that hard
Caption: but
Caption: what's the problem with it
Caption: well firstly having two ways of doing
Caption: things means that
Caption: you have to make sure both ways work
Caption: you might forget to do one of them like
Caption: have you worked on an app with an
Caption: offline mode where someone goes uh yeah
Caption: that's done I just there to make it work
Caption: in offline mode
Caption: or like I said how many of you have
Caption: forgotten to make a particular Feature
Caption: work offline
Caption: so
Caption: there's got to be a better way
Caption: and that way is to build an offline
Caption: first app
Caption: so rather than going from the mindset
Caption: where I have an app that I want to work
Caption: offline
Caption: you say I've got an offline application
Caption: how do I make it work online
Caption: basically you're starting from the
Caption: assumption
Caption: that there is no internet and working up
Caption: from there
Caption: now this comes with a lot of benefits
Caption: um
Caption: like I've already talked about
Caption: the biggest one is that
Caption: it's actually simpler to reason about
Caption: when you've got one way of doing things
Caption: so rather than
Caption: saving to the API or queuing it for
Caption: later
Caption: you basically just always cure for later
Caption: and then you have a background process
Caption: that you know saves into the API later
Caption: which you would have already had anyway
Caption: to handle offline mode
Caption: so
Caption: probably the biggest difference between
Caption: an offline first app and an offline mode
Caption: app is that you're not treating being
Caption: offline as an error Condition it's not a
Caption: special case you need to handle it's
Caption: just how it works
Caption: now I mentioned the term graceful
Caption: degradation before that's basically
Caption: saying I've got an app that's good
Caption: and when it's offline
Caption: it can be almost as good
Caption: the other way to look at it which is
Caption: what offline first is is saying that
Caption: it's a progressive enhancement
Caption: so rather than having something that
Caption: gets worse you actually have something
Caption: that gets better
Caption: so you build a good offline app and when
Caption: it's online you enhance it with other
Caption: things
Caption: that might be that when you go
Caption: to edit a particular item like in your
Caption: to-do list you go
Caption: load the to-do list from the uh from the
Caption: case
Caption: and then hey I'm online so I might as
Caption: well go fetch it and get the new stuff
Caption: so we'll go through that little bit of
Caption: code again and we'll try and change it
Caption: to from offline mode to offline first
Caption: now I said the big problem was if this
Caption: else that
Caption: we get rid of the else and we'll see
Caption: what happens
Caption: it's gone easy so now we have an online
Caption: app that fetches the data and then we
Caption: return the offline data we've actually
Caption: missed one little bit in here so I'll
Caption: make room for that and that's basically
Caption: when we get the new data we have to
Caption: update the offline case as well
Caption: now that's done we can Target the code a
Caption: little bit get rid of some variables
Caption: because who likes variables
Caption: and the codes you know pretty simple if
Caption: you're online do this
Caption: and then always return the offline data
Caption: I mentioned before that waiting for
Caption: things actually makes it slower
Caption: so you can see these async and Away
Caption: words if you're not familiar async just
Caption: says that you can use the await keyword
Caption: and the awake keyword just actually
Caption: waits for it so the program will stop
Caption: and wait for that thing to respond
Caption: if we just get rid of that
Caption: it no longer waits for that response so
Caption: we don't have that issue where it's
Caption: slower because you're online
Caption: now whether or not you can actually do
Caption: this is going to depend on probably a
Caption: framework or something that you're using
Caption: in react you might write a hook that
Caption: abstracts that away
Caption: that's primarily what I write so
Caption: I don't know all the others exactly but
Caption: other reactive Frameworks like Swift UI
Caption: or reactive UI
Caption: felt actually have similar Concepts
Caption: right where you can just update this
Caption: behind the scenes and then show the new
Caption: version
Caption: we can look at our update as well
Caption: and we go
Caption: now we've got that if else but we'll
Caption: tackle it slightly differently
Caption: instead of relying on updating this
Caption: thing as it's happening
Caption: we've already built a robust solution to
Caption: handle those background updates and the
Caption: robustness of that is very important
Caption: we'll talk more about that later
Caption: so I want to just use that we can get
Caption: rid of this whole section entirely
Caption: and we're left with selling pretty
Caption: simple right we update the offline data
Caption: and then we schedule the update for
Caption: later
Caption: this idea of updating the offline data
Caption: is actually really interesting uh has
Caption: anyone heard of optimistic UI or
Caption: optimistic updates
Caption: a couple of people so that's the idea
Caption: basically that
Caption: because it feels slowed away all the
Caption: time let's just update this thing with
Caption: the expectation that it works
Caption: now that is something that happens in
Caption: online apps as well it's it's kind of
Caption: essential in an offline app because
Caption: otherwise you're always looking at old
Caption: data but online apps do this as well to
Caption: try and feel faster they basically want
Caption: that offline experience where things
Caption: just work you know so they
Caption: there are lots of tools now to go and do
Caption: those optimistic updates they get built
Caption: into query libraries like Apollo client
Caption: or route query or things like that again
Caption: I'm mainly working react so those are my
Caption: examples
Caption: so appended a pretty Rosy picture about
Caption: you know how easy it is to make an
Caption: offline app
Caption: and there are a bunch of challenges
Caption: uh we're going to talk about them a fair
Caption: bit after I've had a drink
Caption: [Music]
Caption: so when you talk about offline apps one
Caption: of the big ones that big challenges that
Caption: people will raise is the idea of getting
Caption: a merge conflict now developers are
Caption: pretty familiar with most conflicts
Caption: because we get them all the time when
Caption: we're writing code
Caption: and you won't find many people in the
Caption: room who actually enjoy that process
Caption: but it's not necessarily as big a deal
Caption: as people think it is with an offline
Caption: app
Caption: so I'll just run through a little bit of
Caption: what a most conflict is because it's a
Caption: complicated idea if you're not familiar
Caption: basically emerge conflict happens when
Caption: two people change the same thing around
Caption: the same time
Caption: so in this case we've got Alice and Bob
Caption: Alice opens a thing saves the changes
Caption: and in that in between phase Bob has
Caption: also opened the thing and he saves some
Caption: changes
Caption: now when you get to the end if they've
Caption: made different changes
Caption: you need to figure out what to do
Caption: essentially
Caption: so there's a kind of an important line
Caption: we can draw in the sand which is when
Caption: that first person saves it
Caption: the person who goes after that will get
Caption: a problem
Caption: uh now I've got the lines roughly in
Caption: this kind of range but really they can
Caption: be anywhere
Caption: essentially if you open it before that
Caption: dotted blue line and you save it after
Caption: that dotted blue line then you have a
Caption: problem if you open it and save it
Caption: before the other person gets the problem
Caption: or if you open it after then you're
Caption: already getting the latest updates
Caption: anyway so you're not going to get that
Caption: in those conflict scenario
Caption: the thing is for an offline app
Caption: it's not so much about when you open it
Caption: and when you save it it's more like when
Caption: you were last online to get the version
Caption: at the beginning
Caption: and then when you come back online at
Caption: the end
Caption: so the time frame for actually getting
Caption: emerged conflict when you have an
Caption: offline app is quite a lot bigger
Caption: but the problem is existing no matter
Caption: what you know even if it you've got a
Caption: thing that takes 10 seconds to fill out
Caption: but it's still a 10 second window where
Caption: someone might open it and hit this
Caption: problem so you already do something
Caption: about merge conflicts you probably just
Caption: haven't thought about it
Caption: uh common things that you might find
Caption: there would be that the last update wins
Caption: because they make the change last so
Caption: just overwrite whatever was in there
Caption: with what they put
Caption: hopefully uh some of the changes will be
Caption: the same so actually doesn't matter if
Caption: that if that happened or not
Caption: but there are other approaches you can
Caption: use where rather than say hey here's
Caption: this whole thing you know here's a title
Caption: and description and some tags on how to
Caption: do
Caption: go and replace whatever was there you
Caption: could actually just say all right you
Caption: changed the description so let's update
Caption: the description and that limits the
Caption: amount of most comic books you'll get
Caption: and the idea behind that's kind of like
Caption: a patch operation
Caption: um because it's a HTTP patch keyword and
Caption: an RFC and all this fun stuff around
Caption: that
Caption: but basically most conflicts are a
Caption: problem and you do need to think about
Caption: them but they're already a problem so
Caption: going offline doesn't really change it
Caption: except that you might hit it more
Caption: another one is API versioning and
Caption: backwards compatibility and those kind
Caption: of concerns
Caption: because you may have had an app that was
Caption: yeah last online
Caption: three weeks ago if you've changed the
Caption: API in that three-week period and done a
Caption: breaking change then anyone who comes
Caption: back online from three weeks ago
Caption: yeah the things they're trying to do
Caption: won't work because
Caption: they might be missing required fields or
Caption: that kind of thing right so it becomes
Caption: more important that you accept
Caption: um backwards compatible like old
Caption: versions of stuff so I don't know you
Caption: add a new field to your to-do that's
Caption: called assignee or something
Caption: and then if you make it a required field
Caption: anyone who doesn't provide an assignee
Caption: it'll fail that's kind of a problem
Caption: right so you still need a way for
Caption: someone to do that job without that
Caption: field and a common approach to that is
Caption: having API versioning there are a bunch
Caption: of other ways as well but
Caption: again that's going to depend on what you
Caption: uh where your app works
Caption: you'll notice a common theme around
Caption: these that they're all related to
Caption: handling errors because when everything
Caption: works
Caption: everything works and everything's easy
Caption: the problem is when there are problems
Caption: so another one is things like field
Caption: validation you know if you have a
Caption: required field that you've added
Caption: whether it existed before or exists
Caption: later essentially
Caption: if you rely on the server to validate
Caption: these requests that you're making
Caption: before like rather than letting the
Caption: client do it that means your offline
Caption: user has to wait potentially weeks until
Caption: they actually try and do the thing
Caption: and then it fails so that's a problem
Caption: because
Caption: to go and add a required field when you
Caption: press submit is pretty easy right but if
Caption: you're revisiting it weeks days hours
Caption: even later
Caption: it's a lot harder to to know what the
Caption: right thing to put in is there put in
Caption: there it's
Caption: so I talked about the um the offline
Caption: queue or the the queue of changes to
Caption: make so we've got a little
Caption: animation thing that I'm pretty proud of
Caption: that I made here basically here on that
Caption: process so this little box is going to
Caption: be our magical processor and all the
Caption: little
Caption: rectangles uh other things we're going
Caption: to do with them so we start by
Caption: processing one and we take the next one
Caption: process that
Caption: take the next one and it's failed
Caption: so
Caption: if you went to Derek's talk earlier he
Caption: talked a lot about you know retries and
Caption: timeouts and exponential back off and
Caption: those kind of things and yeah you
Caption: probably do want to retry these requests
Caption: because they might just be intermittent
Caption: errors
Caption: if they're not intermittent errors then
Caption: you retry it and it will always fail so
Caption: what do you do if you talk about a queue
Caption: then there's this idea that you process
Caption: them in the order they came in but this
Caption: one is now stuck
Caption: so you need something to essentially put
Caption: that aside
Caption: and then
Caption: you can continue pressing the rest of
Caption: them
Caption: now you're not done yet that one that
Caption: you didn't process is still
Caption: valid it's still something that someone
Caption: tried to do and it didn't work so you
Caption: need a way for them to resume that
Caption: um it'll depend on again what the app is
Caption: and and what you expect it to do
Caption: but
Caption: basically we need to try and reproduce
Caption: it again in a different way so that
Caption: might be saying you can go back in and
Caption: edit and try again
Caption: or you
Caption: save it to some API and get an admin
Caption: team to process them
Caption: or you just roll it back and say hey
Caption: sorry we couldn't do that throw it away
Caption: again depends on what your data is
Caption: but the kind of robustness of this
Caption: process is is really important because
Caption: it's called your app now so whereas
Caption: before in offline mode it may have been
Caption: there and you didn't spend all of your
Caption: effort building it
Caption: you know maybe you get some problems and
Caption: and it's sort of okay because when
Caption: they're online it works
Caption: but for an offline First Step this is
Caption: the only way you get those updates
Caption: happening so
Caption: again make it robust uh you need to
Caption: think about things like having an item
Caption: potency on your requests
Caption: for example if this was a delete that
Caption: failed because the thing was already
Caption: deleted you could go well you're trying
Caption: to delete it and it's deleted so it's
Caption: fine and just mark it as successful
Caption: basically
Caption: and you might also have the dependent
Caption: requests in here so let's say this was a
Caption: create
Caption: and then later add an update that update
Caption: would also fail because it's got nothing
Caption: to update now so
Caption: they might you might finally get a few
Caption: of these things happening
Caption: another problem is when you have a
Caption: patchy internet connection or an
Caption: unreliable connection rather than being
Caption: just offline
Caption: so it's actually kind of worse
Caption: you could look at the things like
Caption: on your device they often have
Caption: indicators that say whether you're
Caption: online or offline
Caption: but how reliable are they actually you
Caption: might want to put in something like a
Caption: health check endpoint on your API where
Caption: you can call that to see
Caption: like the device says them online but can
Caption: I actually call the apis that I need to
Caption: call
Caption: and then you know base it on that you
Caption: might want to consider
Caption: having the app like manually try and
Caption: sync up rather than doing it
Caption: automatically so the user can say yeah I
Caption: want to sync now but again that doesn't
Caption: work for everyone but it's an approach
Caption: that you could take to handle this
Caption: problem so rather than just responding
Caption: to being online you can wait until the
Caption: person who's like yeah I'm back in the
Caption: office now so I can
Caption: do the thing and it should work
Caption: another thing is when you have an
Caption: offline app you probably need to tell
Caption: your users
Caption: that it's offline and
Caption: uh you could say something like you're
Caption: offline
Caption: but do they know what that actually
Caption: means so rather than just say you're
Caption: offline you might want to change it up a
Caption: little and say something like you're
Caption: offline changes will be saved when
Caption: you're back online
Caption: that kind of hints that
Caption: oh I'm not done just because I think I'm
Caption: done
Caption: there's something else I'll need to do
Caption: again you talk to whoever about the
Caption: exact wording there but
Caption: there's that kind of idea where
Caption: telling them what the state is doesn't
Caption: help tell them what they can do about it
Caption: and then as you go through you might say
Caption: we've got three changes pending upload
Caption: or
Caption: we've uploaded five of eight of your
Caption: changes or you know all changes are
Caption: saved at the end
Caption: just to help the users understand that
Caption: yes you're offline
Caption: and what does it mean for you now you
Caption: know are you done yet when you get this
Caption: kind of message it's like oh cool
Caption: everything I've saved everything I've
Caption: changed has been saved so I can go about
Caption: my day everything's normal
Caption: another one that will be affected by
Caption: having an offline app
Caption: is that
Caption: the security posture of the Europe
Caption: changes
Caption: um
Caption: because you're getting all this data
Caption: onto your device
Caption: is potential that someone else could get
Caption: that data off the device
Caption: so you might want to think about things
Caption: like encryption
Caption: if that's important if you do have
Caption: encryption then where do you store the
Caption: encryption keys if they're also on the
Caption: device then it might be a little I don't
Caption: know pointless to have the key stored
Caption: with the data
Caption: so you think about how that's going to
Caption: work for you another big one is if you
Caption: have shared devices
Caption: uh let's say Yeah in a workplace it
Caption: might be there's a kiosk thing that
Caption: people use to do a job
Caption: and when someone shift ends they hand it
Caption: over to someone else and they'll go do
Caption: their job too
Caption: so if there's kind of user data on there
Caption: you might need to think about
Caption: keeping it separate from the other users
Caption: data
Caption: it's going to defend right maybe it's
Caption: fine for them to see it maybe it's not
Caption: really user sensitive but if you're
Caption: storing
Caption: you know their name or date of birth or
Caption: something somewhere
Caption: then you might want to hide it as well
Caption: so that's where encryption would come in
Caption: and all the other fun things
Caption: and then another kind of complicated
Caption: issue is that most of the apps that we
Caption: build especially if you're going for you
Caption: know Enterprise kind of clients or
Caption: whatever
Caption: you'll need some kind of authorization
Caption: and authentication some like login stuff
Caption: now when you're online you can log in
Caption: and get refresh tokens and you know have
Caption: a token lifetime to last an hour
Caption: and then you go and get a refreshed
Caption: version every hour so that you don't
Caption: never run out right
Caption: if you're offline you can't do that
Caption: anymore so you might need to think about
Caption: how you need to relax those those rules
Caption: those guidelines
Caption: just to handle that scenario so
Caption: you might let people in if their tokens
Caption: expired
Caption: and maybe only for a certain amount of
Caption: time
Caption: but it's probably something you need
Caption: otherwise they can't go offline to more
Caption: than an hour right so it would depend
Caption: again
Caption: I'm a consultant so it always depends
Caption: but if you think about how what it means
Caption: for you you know maybe you let people in
Caption: and then before you actually save
Caption: anything you do go and get that new
Caption: token so that it all works
Caption: but that's the sort of thing you need to
Caption: think about
Caption: another one I've I've got another
Caption: challenge is you want to build
Caption: an offline web app so you could have
Caption: like a mobile app which has its own
Caption: challenges potentially
Caption: but a web app is probably even bigger
Caption: because the convention is that you would
Caption: download everything essentially every
Caption: time you visit the app yeah you might
Caption: have coaching of style sheets and stuff
Caption: through your CDN but if you're going to
Caption: have a fully offline app you need to
Caption: have that data saved on the device
Caption: always
Caption: so there are things to to help you with
Caption: that now like if you build a progressive
Caption: web app a pwa then you get a lot of that
Caption: stuff built in you have a service worker
Caption: download all the assets so for later
Caption: right it's not impossible but it is a
Caption: little bit more difficult probably than
Caption: a native app because the native apps let
Caption: you download all that stuff ahead of
Caption: time anyway you know you download your
Caption: app from the App Store and it's 50
Caption: megabytes or whatever it is and all the
Caption: stuff that you need there is included
Caption: whereas on the web you download that
Caption: every time
Caption: and then the last sort of challenge
Caption: that I've
Caption: I've got to cover I guess is uh
Caption: those features that just won't work so
Caption: you know this is video streaming right
Caption: that's that's not going to work you
Caption: can't build teams of Zoom
Caption: if you're going for an offline app those
Caption: features just won't work so there are
Caption: there are limits
Caption: now
Caption: we've talked a bunch about the benefits
Caption: and the challenges that have come with
Caption: this
Caption: uh we've talked about why you might want
Caption: to build one so if you want to be used
Caption: in remote areas
Caption: or just in situational offline times you
Caption: know someone's probably got a Wi-Fi only
Caption: tablet or something if you wanted to
Caption: bring that here and it didn't work
Caption: because you didn't connect to the
Caption: uh venue Wi-Fi or the venue Wi-Fi was
Caption: bad then you'd have a bad time
Caption: and the benefits I guess are that you
Caption: get a better experience for users they
Caption: can use your app in more ways in more
Caption: places
Caption: and yeah we had to acknowledge that
Caption: there are challenges with that so I'm
Caption: not saying it's easier to build an
Caption: offline app than an online one
Caption: but if you think that you're going to
Caption: build an offline app
Caption: or you know you're going to build an
Caption: offline app or even if you just want to
Caption: build an offline app
Caption: then it's definitely easier to adopt
Caption: that online sorry offline first mindset
Caption: and treat it as the normal rather than
Caption: trying to
Caption: um trying to handle it later you know
Caption: it's easy to know up front what you're
Caption: building and build it from the beginning
Caption: so that's all I've got today
Caption: I didn't think I'd have time for
Caption: questions but I think I actually do so
Caption: if anyone does have a couple
Caption: uh thank you
Caption: foreign
Caption: [Applause]
Caption: yes hello
Caption: I don't know if there's a mic but go out
Caption: and I'll repeat
Caption: that cool so the question was how would
Caption: basically how do you encrypt data on the
Caption: client side
Caption: uh so
Caption: there are many ways to encrypt let's
Caption: assume you've got like a public private
Caption: key pair or something which is a pretty
Caption: standard way to do it you would
Caption: essentially probably rather than
Caption: getting the data
Caption: on your device
Caption: you would download it in an encrypted
Caption: format
Caption: um I would expect and then
Caption: have something on your device to decrypt
Caption: it so if you have a private public key
Caption: for example the private key can stay on
Caption: the server public key on your device the
Caption: way those two things work is that
Caption: anything encrypted by the private key
Caption: can be decrypted by the public key and
Caption: you can verify that that's where it came
Caption: from so that does kind of give you that
Caption: option to to download the data
Caption: uh if you're going to do something like
Caption: encryption that will probably
Caption: dramatically slow down the app because
Caption: you'll have to decrypt it
Caption: all the time and there are going to be
Caption: gaps where it's in memory and stuff so
Caption: when they talk about those kind of hacks
Caption: like um I'm trying to think of the names
Caption: of them but they have all these memory
Caption: overflow like buffer overflow attacks
Caption: and stuff you're probably still going to
Caption: be vulnerable to that kind of stuff it's
Caption: not a perfect solution but there's
Caption: something there right
Caption: cool another one
Caption: foreign
Caption: yeah so
Caption: when we stopped waiting for the response
Caption: and we just kind of updated the
Caption: background
Caption: uh yeah like like you said you would get
Caption: your stale data first and then you'd
Caption: replace it with the new data when it
Caption: came in so it wouldn't always have
Caption: changed and you might see no difference
Caption: but yeah if it did change you'd have to
Caption: handle that so again that's going to
Caption: depend how you want to handle it if
Caption: you're okay with it being
Caption: yeah initially styled data and then
Caption: getting the updated data I guess if you
Caption: don't fetch that data then you would
Caption: always get a stale one so
Caption: is gonna
Caption: yeah so the idea being that if you kind
Caption: of do that process we update it after
Caption: the fact that there's stale data does it
Caption: always make sense to do that
Caption: so
Caption: yeah
Caption: so something like let's say in the top
Caption: right you've got a user Avatar or
Caption: something right if that just updates
Caption: randomly it doesn't matter
Caption: uh if you've just clicked to open
Caption: something and that updates later like
Caption: you said it might be jarring where
Caption: everything changes on them you know
Caption: um
Caption: you'll have to decide what works for you
Caption: potentially you just update lists of
Caption: things like that so you see the old list
Caption: first and then the new one loads in
Caption: there are kind of balances I guess
Caption: it depends but I hate to say that all
Caption: the time but it generally does depend
Caption: cool one more maybe hello
Caption: gosh sorry
Caption: um I don't have any particular thoughts
Caption: on that I guess
Caption: um if it's
Caption: capable of being offline which is
Caption: everything right they've all got an
Caption: airplane mode
Caption: um
Caption: yeah okay yep so
Caption: if I guess it's something I was probably
Caption: meant to talk about but didn't
Caption: um if you're going to download gigabytes
Caption: of data then you're probably going to
Caption: have a bad time because it's all going
Caption: to be on the device so think about
Caption: maybe you only load the last month of
Caption: data or something like that you don't
Caption: necessarily need everything from history
Caption: um
Caption: you might just need stuff that's
Caption: relevant to do your job today while
Caption: you're offline so it could be a very
Caption: small set or it could be quite a large
Caption: set of things you actually need to
Caption: download
Caption: cool all right I think we're probably
Caption: done it's lunch next so I'll wait up
Caption: there and if you have more questions
Caption: come see me
Caption: um otherwise enjoy your food
Caption: foreign